Thanksgiving has ended and here's how
some of our favorite celebs celebrated
Kylie Jenner hosted an extravagant
Thanksgiving dinner with her family Tyga
Kendall Kris and Caitlyn were all
present but noticeably absent from any
Kardashian family photos Kanye West who
remains in the hospital due to
exhaustion Taylor Swift spent the day
frozen on the beach with friends and
family and by that we mean she was
nailing the mannequin challenge before
breaking it down meanwhile BFF Selena
Gomez is resurfacing on social media I
want him to know it's okay she posted a
photo with her fans captioning it my
year has been the hardest yet most
rewarding one yet I finally fought the
fight of not being enough I have only
wanted to reflect the love you guys have
given me for years and show how
important it is to take care of you Katy
Perry and Orlando Bloom shut down
breakup rumors looking cozy in pjs as
they get ready to eat turkey another
celeb couple going strong Blake Shelton
and Gwen Stefani who shared a sweet
smooch skier Lindsey Vonn is on the men
from her fractured arm but is still
feeling thankful posting this collage of
friends family and her boyfriend at
Kenan Smith another athlete feeling
thankful LA Rams Rodger Saffold who
spent his Thanksgiving volunteering he
and his family handed out meals to paths
homeless and formerly homeless clients
at pink taco in Los Angeles
you